I just think that you should think that
every decision is right and I think most
people think every decision is wrong
like most people just go into like did I
make the right this there's just this
unbelievable ability to beat oneself up
to be cynical to be pessimistic to be
fear-based and I'm just trying to get
people to flip it because life is
actually how it plays out in your head
it just actually is like my ability to
turn every negative into a positive is
very real and and I watch many people
taking positives and turning into
negatives it's very real life is a
perspective game and we need to have
more positive optimist at the end you
got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
I am ready to get into it so Dustin if
you want to get the first question go in
here I am ready to go big shout out to
Brandon Britain who's with us oh there
we go
Leon what is good my man good morning
Gary
good morning yeah I get to be on with
you absentee thank you love it yeah so
yeah my question is what do you think a
number three or number four person in
the business should should look like in
terms of putting themselves out there
and getting themselves known because I'm
in a bit of that spot right now where
I'm like falling out of love of like
social media coaching for businesses so
I'm just trying to switch myself and and
you're you you know for everybody's
watching who doesn't understand what
Leon's referring to what you've heard
from me Leon is hey there's a lot of
people that could be great number twos
threes fours five six seven who could
quote unquote make more money being a
number six at vaynermedia than they
would have as being a number one in
whatever hustle or business that they've
started for themselves and so you're
saying you've been doing coaching
consulting and things of that nature and
now you want to produce content to give
you leverage to be hired as a number
three or four yeah I think so I feel I
feel that way because I've been trying
to do it myself like I don't like you
enough yeah like I don't get I get get
up excited every morning about it I
totally get it and I think you know it's
one of the things that I'm talking about
that I'm most proud of because I'm
trying to create permission and
self-awareness to not have to be an
entrepreneur in a world where if you're
under 40 you know most feels like you
have to be which is crazy it's almost
like become like entrepreneurship so
must become like school in college
everyone thinks you have to mm-hmm so
couple things the first thing I probably
do is make a list of the 25 businesses
and 25 entrepreneurs you most admire if
you can even make a list that big
because one of the things you can
consider is spending a couple weeks just
analyzing those businesses
obviously if you've been an entrepreneur
or doing your own thing it's likely for
you to be a three and four in probably a
company that's probably between 50 25
maybe to a hundred people you're not
gonna go be number three or four and
Amazon or Netflix or BMW yeah right so
so you probably want to focus on the
entrepreneur in the sector that you most
enjoy and then there's two things to do
one you really analyze their business
and you start putting out content about
Manny's pizza shop or vaynermedia or or
you know whatever the company is you
start actually making content like
literally like analyzing their social
media and saying you know you know
literally on LinkedIn you the title is
you know three things I see the great
tea shop can fix on social media
literally so that's one way the other
way is to literally write an email to
you know dear Sally Thompson I've
admired your business from afar for a
long time I love video game you know
choch goes and you do it better than
anybody else let me just tell you a
little bit about myself if there's
anything I can ever do pro bono please
let me know that's one version that's
asking the other version is the email
that is similar to the blog post dear
Sally pants you know I've always loved
your eSports trinket business you know
with Corona I've had some time on my
hands I spent the last half a week
analyzing your social below are seven
things that I would highly recommend you
pay attention to that can make your
social media prep profile better no ask
no anything just like thank you so much
if there's anything I can help you with
in the future please hit me back
love you Leon those three tactics
against a human are the things that will
work cool all right yeah thanks man I
appreciate you get on it first
first figure out who you admire it's
okay to take a month right now and try
to consume a ton of entrepreneurs and a
ton of small business and where do you
live in Montreal in Canada
love it there's a lot of interesting
creative stuff going on to Montreal
if you don't want to leave that area you
should really do homework mmm huh nice
man yeah I'm gonna be going into the
vegan market love that there so that's
where your passion is
yeah I'm really interested in that stuff
and I'm putting out more content about
food and there's a ton of vegan startups
direct-to-consumer vegan brands that I'm
sure your social media consulting and
coaching can help it's similar to where
I told you to audit their page and then
DM them or email them awesome
okay so let's go yeah of course Leon if
you are on and sharing there we go David
Hendon sang well very good job Tim newly
very good I'm gonna share you Kim and
give you the follow beat Kim the big
[ __ ] follow for Tim make gains big
follow for him Nate
I am now your 880 second follower hello
my man
hey um first off I wanna say thank you
you brought a lot of good content and
even though I haven't needed to follow
it for like two years I've been
consuming it for two years and it's very
motivating and all that thank you
what's your name my friend I'm Khan Khan
and were you from yeah I was born in
grace but I've grown up in Australia
since I was like three I love it nice to
be you con thank you nice to meet you
too um okay sorry
is there alright if I give some content
context first before my question is
don't worry get around my word I'm sure
so pretty much I'm in my second year of
university or like equivalents calling
you guys now I'm doing sports and
exercise science and my goal is that
eventually I want to work in high
performance for recently I started about
a month ago I started branding myself a
lot more I started my Instagram side
might I've got a website now LinkedIn
and all that and pretty much I wanted
shared who I am what I'm learning and
all that
but what like what I've been wondering
is just how I can provide more valuable
considering that I am a younger more
experienced inexperienced coach because
I say all of the content that other more
experienced people putting out it's like
I don't I don't know where my place is
really you know your places and
hypotheses and opinions because what you
don't have is experience yet right and
you don't have the leverage of results
from athletes right and so you're in a
very similar place to where I was when I
first walked into the wine library which
was I had ideas I'm sure you have ideas
of and hypotheses and opinions but right
now to your point you know we're a lot
of 22 year olds 20 year olds 18 year
olds get caught is they think only
expertise can bring leverage to business
and what they end up doing is they fake
it until they make it and they start
talking about [ __ ] that they don't know
about and and and what I mean by that is
it's one thing con if you say hey if
your video is literally like this hey
you know I can't wait to eventually try
out this thesis but something that's
been on my mind is if people use ice and
heat three hours before or or if they
eat you know I would share ideas a most
people don't like to share ideas because
they think people will steal them and I
don't think people understand that the
world is abundant plus if you put it out
on the internet first it's almost like
you own it it can't really necessarily
be stolen number two you don't have any
other choice con until you have you know
clients until you have 15 years of
experience you don't and so the thing
that you have to do for sure there's a
lot of things that you don't have to do
but the one thing you have to do is be
very careful not to make things up or
fake it til you make it I see this every
day 20-year old life coaches 20 year old
biz 20 or that and they just and I
understand I've empathy for them they're
they're just kind of almost lying
bullshitting embellishing tricking
to seem like an authority when they're
not and that will never work in the end
it might work short-term you might get
something out of it in the short term
but long term you always get exposed so
for me what you need to do is document
the journey of becoming who you're gonna
become and that's more talking about
frustrations talking about trying out
some theories on your friends cuz real
athletes won't let you talking about
ideas you have doing green school you
know how I have this green screen right
now this tea set up you know you do it
you know how you see on tick-tock people
making content over other people's
videos maybe you start sharing your
opinions on other people's videos
there's a lot of ways you can go about
it but the number one mistake the common
mistake the thing I see 90% of time of
kids in this position they start making
up [ __ ] and they always will get caught
on that well I think what you're saying
makes sense and I think that it would be
good just like like even going for just
having you back lagers this is what I've
done this is what I say like what you're
saying makes sense I think the other bit
that I get caught on is if I should even
be bothering trying to share and trying
to promote my soul and I might now
address it you should I'll tell you
watching Oh guys because one day you're
gonna be 81 and it's gonna be so
powerful that video for your
sixteen-year-old great-grandson yes so
you think that's worth it still cuz cuz
this is the time I'm coming from is John
I don't know yeah it's worth it for you
the human being may be not worth it for
you the business sports business side
yet
you'll be you know how I'm at my parents
house do you know sad I am I don't have
pictures of me a baseball card shows I'm
devastated I wish I had them
I wish I had pictures of me at the
lemonade saying I wish I had a video of
me washing cars shoveling snow the
reason you need to do it is for your
great-grandchildren and for yourself one
day to look back on not to create
business you understand yeah not that
makes sense
and by the way where's that what if what
if God willing you become one of the
great players in your field and they
have to make a documentary about you the
video will be really good for the
documentary yeah let's take one what one
day you're not gonna have that much hair
so be nice to have video with that much
hair think of it in the macro not in the
micro yeah okay that makes sense I'm
real quick one last thing yeah and God
willing by accident you make you may
make one video that resonates with
millions of people why not yeah yeah
okay but that makes sense yeah cuz I
think the thing is I I enjoy it it's
just I was having trouble justifying to
myself great because if you enjoy it I
just gave you very clear black and white
justifications yeah okay can I ask one
more quick question please going off of
the document or the create kind of a
thing that you're saying that I should
be following regarding LinkedIn what I
currently do is I only post when I get a
longer form post like a blog post on my
blog and then I share that to LinkedIn
also do you think that just shorter form
like this is what I've done this week
tried it right I got try it I'm not sure
but try it okay the the answer what's
great about the internet and that
everybody [ __ ] up is trying it and
getting back the feedback after 10 times
of doing the short thing this is what I
did this week and it's not working is
more valuable than debating it or asking
an expert
yeah okay thank you so much thank you
bye bye bye alright let's go back to
Twitter before we go there's Amanda
Lambert Amanda you get a follow Amanda I
am your 150th follower Remy my good
friend Ramiz in the building Sandra
smaller sensor Sandra you gonna follow
such hardcore community member debonair
examiner is always in the mix I love
that hey Leslie hi Gary how are you
thank you where you from I'm from
Florida
so Dana Florida so my question to you is
I mean just a little background I'm a
branding and web designer most of my
clients are they're kind of all over the
world Muslim are creatives probably 70%
photographers the rest creatives artists
things like that I've been doing this
for coming on twelve years so I feel
like my business is you started when you
were six I'm actually 36 years old I
look 12 sounds good yeah I don't help so
I've been I so I have 12 years
experience I feel like I have a lot of
value to offer but I just I love what I
do so much that I'm always like I'm
hearing all these voices of like oh you
should do a course or to offer value and
I know there's a lot I can offer but I I
just love what I do I don't want
anything else so I feel like good good
news you've won yeah
like am i am i doing a dis justice to
other designers that I can teach things
like I just don't feel like I don't
think about of course I don't think I
don't think that that's really
necessarily where your energies coming
from it's probably coming from your
logical entrepreneurial brain and other
voices that you're leaving money on the
table not that you're not helping if
that's the case you wouldn't sub course
like for example my Greek like want
what's pulling at my heartstrings is to
be the most helpful entrepreneur to
other entrepreneurs in the history of
entrepreneurship which is why I don't
have masterminds and courses it's why I
put out everything for free
yeah yeah right so I think to your point
and I could feel the energy you know
that there's some business opportunity
there it's more quote unquote scalable
but you just don't give a [ __ ] and good
news less you're just like me
I find to make so much more money than I
make I just don't want to I want to be
ya not have more money yeah I mean I'm
enjoying that I am making a little more
money now because it's taken 12 years to
get here
that's like can't I just I just want to
I don't need to make a million dollars
like that's right I'm good we just
bought the house we've always wanted we
you know like we're in a good place I do
want to travel more so I need more for
my travel jar well what what you might
be able to do then is why don't you put
out free zooms and free live streams
which will build up your personal brand
it's all free which will probably lead
to invites to give some speeches I've
been able to travel the world and not
pay a dime so you might be able to get
you know places that you know at first
the first at first my offers were will
pay for your travel you know back in oh
nine when I started speaking out I think
that's that would be a homerun for you
if somebody reaches out to you from
Australians like will pay for your
travel can you come and speak you got
you like hang up and dance all over the
building yeah yeah totally I would so I
think there's a way for you to do that
as well which is to start putting out
more free content and when I say content
one of things I need to talk about more
is put out more free access you know
what I'm doing right now is the most
valuable
right the most valuable I mean like
people people buy fifty sixty eighty
thousand dollar one hour lunches with me
through charity things that I do you
know like this one-on-one time is
something people want and and I'm doing
it right now for free you know and so
you can do that as well
let access to your facebook lives you
know into their lives zooms and then and
then I think that will lead to demand
for you to speak and that will scratch
your travel the answer is don't listen
to your husband don't listen to your
best friend
don't listen to some of the experts that
you follow and Instagram you do not have
to start a course cuz it's more scalable
make more money you have to follow what
makes you happiest and you are clearly
in tune with that and so I'm proud of
you thank you thank you yeah I do love
what I do and I'm always like preaching
it to other people like if you hate your
job just like I just have to try you
have to try and everybody goes everyone
most people are fear-based so they're
like how am I going to pay the rent and
this and that and I keep reminding
people quit your job in parallel with
quitting your lifestyle actually sell
your home and your car and your fancy
handbags and sneakers and go rent an
apartment and then quit happiness over
everything yeah yeah I agree
yeah let's my friends are six or selling
them less yeah
access do some streams you're gonna
stumble on somebody who's thrown a
conference who's gonna pay for you to
travel and then you'll figure out if
you're good at speaking in front of us
and if you if you are you'll travel the
whole world awesome
thank you so much Gary you're welcome
less I write back to Twitter if you are
not sharing screenshots of this on your
Twitter you're making a huge mistake
because you are missing out on some epic
following which I think you should not
do that Krystal big shout out to you you
I am your fifty-fifth follower look at
this crew
I mean dressed up looking sharp kill me
how are you Gary how are you good
and what's your name
very nice to meet you nice to meet you
really excited thanks for having us
today so we live in New Jersey we do
real estate in Manhattan and following
you for a few years honestly I think a
few months ago you told us to stop
following you and just do it about three
years
I left a w-2 plane job you know making
six figures haven't quite made up where
it needed to be real estate now or can
be client scheduled houses can pool call
can do anything for you to reset and we
use this time amongst many things to do
a reset in my business so what are your
ideas as a real estate real estate
agents we are marketing let me throw
some random things at you number one
have you have you considered starting a
Facebook group for a tri-state I would
call the tri-state real estate group
where real estate agents real estate
brokers you know just just a community
one of the biggest things I believe in
is throw the party you know right now
tell me it's less about that how active
that are you in there and who are you
letting in there one we won we just saw
like two weeks ago that was really just
potential clients the second one we took
over from a guy who's helping us that's
open to agents Pass open everyone I
believe I think intent really matters
kill me so what I'm trying to do is get
you to be the Pied Piper the Gatsby the
person that throws the party
and even if people in there are doing
more real estate transactions and there
may be times where you look at each
other and said why do we listen to Gary
there's these other real estate agents
that are part of these creeps that are
also taking the business from the people
that are in this group that have
potential clients I still believe that
in the macro being the person that has
the number-one tri-state real estate
group as the host or hostess will turn
out to be ROI beneficial in a two three
year period what that requires is the
intent of you when you have that group
is for you to actually be a host not you
through them all they're just to sell
them a property that's a very different
mentality it leads to very different
words and very different thoughts coming
out of your mouth
so one of the things that I think most
you know my sister's a real estate agent
in New Jersey so I'm not closer to it
one of the biggest mistakes that I think
real estate agents make is they don't
mark it they don't bring value they are
salespeople right there and so to me
every time since I spoke at the first
Inman connect in like 2010 my first time
we connected 2010 or 11 I kept saying be
the mayor of your town be the newspaper
of your town you know what I would do if
I were you right now is I would think
about all the businesses that are
struggling in Manhattan as well I would
probably reach out on Twitter and
Instagram
and DM and on LinkedIn and DM our
restaurant and other owners in Manhattan
and interview them how they're getting
through the storm and then post these
interviews on Facebook because I in
Manhattan what may happen is you may
make you may interview the one chef who
cries during the interview who's a
famous New York chef that's the
interview that gets picked up by ABC
News it's the interview that gets a
million views on Facebook even with your
incredibly intriguing quirky style
you'll be memorable you I think it's
about content it's about content I've
been consistent about this kill day as
you know but the reality is it's the
intent behind the content I
want you to be thinking that your CNN
that your the New York Post that your
Bloomberg you need to be thinking about
how do I bring value to this restaurant
owner and even though and and the
reality is a lot of people are sitting
home and willing to do interviews right
now you'll be able to make some
friendships but you have to convert and
I believe every real estate agent will
she and he will achieve their best when
they convert into being a news
organization not a Salesman I really
believe that and so I believe like you
know I believe that people need to
interview their principals their
superintendents they're the owners of
the businesses that have been there a
long time
I think this advice works even better
for people in smaller towns in Manhattan
but but I said but I still know it works
in Manhattan and on the flip side
there's no small town interview that's
gonna get national coverage but if you
get the right chef or the right barber
with the right thing and your tiny
little audience on Facebook and you
posted it starts with thirteen views the
way Facebook and YouTube work is you can
wake up and has a million views I think
you should quadruple down on interviews
and stories I think you know I've said
it a bunch of last couple days I'm sure
maybe you've picked up on this I think
the two of you need to tell the story of
if you meet five different videos on why
you quit a six-figure job w-2 like and
when I here hasn't gotten there yet
there's a lot of power in your stories
kill but you you can help a lot of
people and you can you can get people
emotionally attached to your story I
think you need to go into story time and
newscaster time that's what I would do
[Music]
host and post them everywhere right like
you know I'm doing this with tea with
Gary be the videos are about to show you
know this little clip will show up on
Instagram I'll show that LinkedIn will
show up at Facebook will show up on
Twitter all produce the video and then
distribute it in all different platforms
and the only differences you might title
it a little different you might add some
words that are a little different I'm
you say LinkedIn crowd is a little
different than the tik-tok around you
mean you might write copy that
associates the video a little bit
different but distribute everywhere you
never want to
get yourself a chance to be discovered
okay one question get besides that
outside the Hat so we all like to dance
oh sorry I also teach Brazilian dance we
dance swing so we also use desk tick
tock tick tock tick tocks a huge
opportunity for you okay so it does make
me do dancing maybe if you two made
tick-tock
if you two did the trending dance every
day on tick-tock
I guarantee somewhere in the next year
one of those will go viral and that may
lead to somebody who lives in Brooklyn
in Bushwick clicking on your profile
seeing that you do real estate and then
emailing you because they're moving into
the city
that's how it actually works that is how
it works
Oh keep the heads keep the dance keep
the energy keep of course keep the hats
and dance cuz you guys like that exactly
what are we doing here right you know
obviously we want to reach we want to
reach our financial goals for our
stability and things of that nature but
at the end of the day how you make your
money is more important than how much
you make and the hats and a dancing is
part of your to souls
you're more content thank you or you
know sake you'll be I was in grapes
thank you very much great job yes with
your father he'll be you better sign up
for wine text my dad needs it it's a
great service if you buy wine it's crazy
good everybody you buy wine on the
internet wine Tex calm today we are
selling a fifty to fifty two dollar
Pinot Noir for twenty like half price
like it's just ridiculous great plant
trainers thank you so much 16 blended
collective CBS Kabam yogi Jerry thank
you so much wrapping me on and thank you
so much appreciate it love your show
thank you oh you're welcome
about me I started an Instagram back in
2016 to make fun of yoga practice just
to make fun of yoga and it you know get
a change in my life and now I have like
a yoga brand I teach yoga I post
everywhere like Facebook tik-tok you
know just everywhere because you so I
appreciate like everything you said
everything you do my friend Pedro told
me that told me to listen to you and you
literally changed my life I got it a
$30,000 of debt because I sold my house
and I moved in with my in-laws for like
four or five months so that like for
five months was tough but it set my
whole future up so much better with like
my side hustle business and everything
like that so thank you so much for that
so yo so Brian you literally heard me
talk about that theory
it's sat in your head and you decided to
do it I did yeah it sat in my head and I
was like really playing with the fears
of like may the judgment judgment I'm 38
years old and like I just got married to
last year so it's like the judge will
probably say I'm so proud of you
oh thank you thank you so much oh you
don't courage it takes to do that move
but I'm so more proud of you because
right now people can sense your
happiness with it and so many people
have to sell their home and move in with
their in-laws they have and with their
friends they don't realize it's it's a
huge coup it's a huge coup if you can't
afford your lifestyle to reset a little
humidity and by the way I have no idea
how much you like or don't like your
in-laws but one of the things that
people don't realize and I've gotten
some of these emails going back in with
their appearance or their best friend or
their in-laws or the cut one guy went in
with their high school coach also those
three four five six months have been a
lot of fun for a lot of people because
they got closer to people that they like
yeah yeah you know it's a great time and
laws are awesome that a pool so it's
during the summer yeah I was like a
little think about it were they
practical and like hey Brian that's
really like did they view it as a they
also see it as it's like wow good on you
that you had the courage to do a judge
yeah super supportive super supportive
than in judge they enjoyed us being
there so we and there's just time we
live in an apartment now so if course
honey and now we're waiting to possibly
buy a house from this whole thing course
yeah it's such a big big relief off my
shoulders just able to focus you know
more on just my brain what I want to do
because I work on I work at a bank on my
day job and like I'm literally like go
go go every minute outside my day job
even I'm like if I'm walking down the
hall whatever I come on my phone try to
respond back to people and that was my
question that I had today is I'm making
all this content I love to make people
laugh especially in the yoga community
that's like my passion I love to be an
entertainer I love to make people laugh
especially right now I feel
as a creator a responsibility to make
people laugh and just kind of get them
out of this rut but especially since
I've been home and I make content I try
to respond back to everyone's dm's and
just build that community how do you
have any advice on managing just being
on my phone so much like do you like for
example do you like batch your texts or
do you only go on Instagram at certain
times of the day like how do you balance
because I feel like I'm gonna almost
crossing the line of cell phone
addiction to just because I have a wife
I have ass I don't think I'm here I
don't think you have cell phone
addiction I think you have addiction to
your passion you know the cell phone
just happens to be signed up for one
text
he's my welcome right you don't have an
addiction to your phone you have
addiction to what's on the other side
the phone is an empty pipe and so and if
you're feeling guilt that you want to
spend a little more time with the fam
then that's on you that's not the phone
it's not the phone it's what's on the
other side of the phone people have it
so confused everyone's like you're
addicted to your phone no you're
addicted to your friends that you talk
to us addicted the phone no not you're
addicted to watching funny videos you're
on you're addicted to you know your
business so III think you're addicted to
the right thing
joshan on the side hustle don't demonize
yourself because you're on the phone cuz
you know what that's another judgment
for society society judges people to
sell their home and go and live with
their in-laws you have just felt the
benefits of that society judges people
on their phone but they don't realize
what's happening on the other phone
you're making people happy on the other
side yes that's true that's right of you
I don't look down on you I look up at
you for that thank you appreciate it and
thank you for getting me on tick-tock I
love tick-tock and just I love consuming
the content and like it yeah it really
blows up pretty fast on there you know
my whole like brand like transformed now
I'm like doing cussing yoga videos and
like it's just yes so
transform so appreciate that why'd you
ever thought of them I overthought
tick-tock I started in July and I kept
deleting videos like I kept them like
not doing good is it's time that
everybody realizes that I get more
enjoyment from my content that doesn't
do well than the reverse not doing well
is not bad not doing well is a gift it
shows you and it gives you data on
something it lets you know that
something might not be working specially
after you do the same thing 50 times
after one time you can't just think it's
not doing well and you have to have the
confidence to let somebody come on your
page and see that you only had 37 views
yeah yes you started a Facebook group we
have we actually do turn me on to you we
have a we have all right Facebook every
way I just do I do what you tell me so I
appreciate appreciate you so much thank
you have a great day crazy man proud of
you listen that ain't got had everybody
that had a huge piece of content in it
which is the bottom line is I'm telling
you if you don't understand the step
back on selling your home if you can't
afford it if you can't afford it it is
one of the great moves in our society
and I hope more people do it proud of
Brian did you just see the happiness and
the confidence in his eyes unbelievable
Jen how are you hi guys
nice to see you so my my name is
Jennifer Dalton I live in East Meadow
New York I just want to start off by
saying thank you for this once in a life
opportunity and I loved your video
yesterday with your dad I was laughing
it was amazing and it reminded me a lot
of my relationship with my father and
how you know I've been in the kitchen
with him since I'm 4 years old breaking
up the ends of string beans and just
building that worth ethic that is like
so valuable so I love your tea with
Carrie be show this past year I had a
pretty challenging year um where I of
the stuff that people were saying
resonated with me I mean I had to move
out of my home I trade in my fancy BMW
move back with my parents I haven't paid
my bills in about a year due to some
hardships and both before quarantine I
was working three part-time jobs and
what I learned is that I love connecting
the people I love people I love the
different groups of people and my dream
is to open up a coffee shop where I
could build a like community yeah and
have like speakers come in and have
events and have an experienced teacher
cooking you know I like and Jen Jennifer
yeah Matt front also debate if it want
if you want it to be a coffee shop
because that's a very kind of like
competitive sector and I see a lot of
people who want to connect with people
and have a hub default into coffee shop
just after this call play with the idea
of should it be an arcade should it be a
ham curated bookstore should it be a G
store should it be tea should it be
orange juice maybe it's straight maybe
it's string beat maybe it's a suit store
like beep I love the idea don't just
default into coffee shop a lot of people
are doing that now coffee
be the right one for you but I love the
idea for people that love connecting
with people that are extroverted and
what a clubhouse and build a business
around it I just want to make sure I
actually think some people out there
like you actually have a better idea in
them but they don't think that like for
example they don't think they can open a
great food store right Rea so
grapefruits Rea so grapefruit juice but
meanwhile it was their grandma
and there's favorite drink and with that
passion they'll stand out more and do
even better selling grapefruit
grapefruit t-shirts like then they would
have been a coffee shop because they
don't realize yes there might be ten
times more people that want coffee than
grapefruit but there's 12 coffee shops
to divide that demand
whereas with grapefruit there isn't a
single grapefruit store around so just
also keep in mind that there might be
something unique for you to do as well
just something to keep in mind keep
going beautiful yeah I was thinking like
especially with everyone being home and
maybe some jobs like getting used to
being at home people are gonna want a
place to come and do their work and
maybe rent out like rooms where people
could you know do that cluster of houses
club houses will always work yeah like
that third place environment so like I
also love what you do and I love I feel
like I've been through quite a bit of my
life to where I could connect with
people on a very deep level and I was
wondering if you were me like what would
you do to explore that focus like energy
and that focused meaning you want to
build a community and talk with oh yeah
you know I would do what I did you know
in 2009 in 2006 I started in 2006 I
started doing it with wine and then in
2009 I started doing with business it's
literally as simple as making videos and
putting them out on the Internet back
then that was bid ler YouTube Facebook
and Twitter myspace right today it's a
slew of things from tic toc to LinkedIn
to other places but what's really crazy
Jennifer is the it's very obvious what
it is it is content it's a podcast it's
a youtube show it's it's one-off videos
it's starting with six people that are
your friend
him you know and then it builds from
there it's really as simple as that
there is nothing too crazy to the
strategy the crazy part to the strategy
is the ability to execute so I've been
hosting wellness events like every month
and I rent out a storefront and then I
have like 10 to 12 people come in and
finish and try to fill different things
no good so next one you do have a friend
film it literally everyone's like but
then what this literally and on the
iPhone if they have to you should
absolutely film it because that's
content maybe you getting somebody to
try something are you saying something
to somebody that's there is the video
that starts your career thank you so
much you're welcome
have a great day okay friends everybody
just like with Jennifer right now it is
documenting like do not do anything
that's public without it being filmed
and then chop it up and put in the world
very nice so I my question is this I am
26 years old right now and I really feel
I stood behind like some advice on how
to boost my resume and convince others
that I have a lot to offer and I am very
passionate about Latin and I think the
answer is less about boosting your
resume and it's more about
asking more people so I see a lot of
people who feel insecure about their
resumes whether they're behind they
didn't go to the best school and I
always laugh because I always say to
them you don't understand it's not about
having the best resume it's about asking
the most people for a job so to me you
have more than a good enough resume for
one to five hundred businesses in the
world right now right now it's just that
you have to submit your resume and you
have to reach out to them and apply so
so many people are in their head
worrying and dwelling that it's they're
behind instead they should be on
LinkedIn and reaching out to CEOs and
CFOs and CIOs and CTOs in your situation
and sending in the resume and saying I
have the most passion read this resume
all you need is one person to say yes so
it's about quantity with a good I'm
gonna let I'm gonna finish that cuz a
lot of people watching cuz you I could
see that you got it in its quantity with
upfront context in the first two or
three sentences to get them to get
excited and then you're on your way
it's if you know you're sending it to
it's if you know you're sending your
resume to a video game maker you make a
reference to loving you know Zelda when
you were a kid you know just something
to give it a little boost that's it if
you if you're applying to a company in
Poland you make a reference in the
opening email about somebody that you
grew up with in Greece who was from
Poland if that's true you know you give
a little a little flavor to it
I see thank you very much my second
question is this I have this in the
Premiership each with my twin brother
and yes and we are trying to start some
cycling
besides our main jobs because it's not
our goal
financial freedom and it's I feel like
it's in Europe it's very different than
in America for it is my brother has
started lighting and she's really trying
to fly her clients and create a career
out of it and I was thinking about
flipping and side hustles doing in
Europe but I understand it's very
difficult from America it's not so it's
right it's not as easy it's not there
the websites aren't the same it's
different and regulations are different
and I was asking if you have any any
advice on either going for flipping and
if yes what to study about it because I
am ready to do it or some other thing is
definitely harder in Europe than it is
in the US because the websites the
culture there's a lot of differences I
do see some people in Europe doing very
well in flipping by starting an
Instagram account and posting their
items on Instagram and then people reply
and then they meet up and they change it
so I were they ship it so I've seen some
Europeans get some traction on flipping
by posting the items on Instagram and
like literally starting an account that
says selling from Greece and just taking
a photo and saying $80 for this hats and
$4 for this mug and so I've seen some
success like that but let's go back to
the most important part it's very
important to me and we talked about it
to callers ago with Brian when I heard
you say financial freedom panatela just
remember one thing
financial freedom comes in a lot of
forms it comes in how much you make but
more importantly comes in how much you
spend of course it is and I think this
generation everybody 15 to 35 needs a
good good good reminder that you don't
have to buy the most expensive home you
can afford the most expensive car you
can afford like we need to live a little
more
humbly because it's gonna lead to a lot
more breathing room to live with
financial freedom yes about doing stuff
and having experience like that so
listen I think the flipping can be done
on Instagram and I think I think that
there's a lot of other things you can
consider I I think when you have the
ability to be a developer like you are
you might be able to develop some stuff
on the side that you know that people
pay five dollars a piece for for a
download like there's a lot of clever
stuff developers can do a little hack
that helps people make their content
better that they pay two dollars a month
for subscription low low cost
subscription technology I think is a
very interesting business maybe you
start something that is like a software
that helps people make better tik-tok
videos and it cost $3 a month all of a
sudden that can be an interesting
business so I would maybe a side hustle
that leans into your natural strengths
of development so this goes this goes
more for a macro kind of stuff because
you have to gain the experience and
create more that's right okay thank you
very much thank you let's keep the scope
Ryan what's good hey Gary thank you so
much for having me
what are you from I'm from Chicago I
actually had a quick tip for Pantelis
because I'm a software engineer please
so if if the company that you're
applying for has a public product or API
take a small part of that product and
build it and bring it to the interview
agreed use that couple times and it's
really good you know make it you know
making and doing over talking always
works and that's what you're talking
about Ryan so I appreciate that so my
question is so last week I had the idea
of selling printed images on toilet
paper and I contacted a guy who
is willing to drop ship them for me and
I started a Shopify store Facebook
Instagram page and that's as far as I've
gotten
I've sold two toilet papers went to my
mom and went to my best friend so start
good start
I'm curious if you have any advice for
what can I do I was thinking that
Facebook ads or Instagram ads might be a
way to try and kick it off but do you
have any advice really really like in
ceramics story ads they're underpriced
they have a functionality when you're
like I mean literally here's what I
would do I'll just do the whole thing
for you
what's up Instagram it's Ryan I'm about
to tell you something crazy
I've started a toilet paper that we
printed things on if you want to swipe
up to find out more I know it's crazy
and I know right now toilet paper is
kind of like a thing in our culture but
I'm telling you check it out
swipe up now that add onion stream
stories is gonna cost you so little and
if you target 25 to 29 year olds you can
also do like what's up Chicago its Ryan
I live here too I'm an entrepreneur
that's had an idea last week this toilet
paper has print on it I know it's crazy
you know I know there's a shortage of
toilet paper there's really not so don't
be mad at me swipe up if you want to
check it out that ad why that ads
interesting is now you target it on the
back end Chicago you are from Chicago
you created a connection point notice
how I went right to it in the first
three seconds every instrument story and
you have to win in the first three
seconds or you're dead you know how fast
we go through Instagram stories right so
you holding up the visual of the so
you're gonna meet a roll sent to you
because obviously you have somebody
trapped shipping you holding that up and
quickly saying what's up guys I'm Ryan
from Chicago like literally or I'd
probably go this route Chicago stand up
it's me right you know like you're
really trying to stop people because but
Instagram story ads are super
underpriced the swipe up functionality
sends to your shopify right and you
could be so targeted with it and then
what you'll learn that Chicago works is
you're gonna start where did you go to
college but it appears where drop out
DePaul University even better so you can
target by DePaul you can be like DePaul
I went to the pot like like you start
like really going segmented you can
start and then you could by the way you
don't have to be from Chicago to say hey
Chicago you can literally be like New
York what's good you know
so I think insurance story ads swipe up
to your shopify are going and I want you
to be in it and like literally just do
that ad it will work awesome I'll do it
to me to me that is the number one
conversion Shopify tactic sitting there
if you hit if you hit the creative I
always want people no matter how
extroverted or introverted they are to
star in the ad cuz people stop people
stopped when they see people mm-hmm
here's like I don't know if we can
target by humor or humor interests I
don't know if that's still in play but
like it's just like god there's
definitely I definitely feel like a
psychological graph of like people that
find things funny would probably
resonate with the print you know like I
mean there's something there's something
clearly there so much the first one I
did was a Donald Trump toilet paper so
it's yes so I was our case I would
target Democrats because you wouldn't do
as well with Republicans you know that
right and then and then and then you
know then you do the Biden one for the
other side and then you do read it well
like there's just like there's a lot to
do there so I think I think that there's
a lot of you'll clearly get a lot of
reaction if you run that piece of native
in New York and California where people
skew more liberal than conservative like
that's gonna if you can target by
California New York target by humor
interests you're gonna you're gonna get
some track into it I'm telling you right
now now that I hear how polarizing the
concept is I would definitely do in
screwed story swipe ups a good today
today okay I have another one that is
like Cove in 1900 the paper roll with
tips on how to keep themselves safe I
think I think you understand the
creative that will get people to react
and by I think to your point you need
the marketing strategy to build
awareness I'm getting more confident on
the Instagram swipe up ads as you add
context do I need
on the actual pages of the Facebook
Instagram do I need to be posting that
yes since you don't - yes cuz you've got
a I mean look you should probably post
that Donald Trump and kovat post in your
feed and tag a bunch of celebrities
inevitably somebody's gonna respond to
that you know like I would prop me you
know I don't have any I don't know what
the max tagging is I'm Instagram trying
to remember if it's 10 or 20 people or
30 whatever but I'd probably post the
same post over and over just tagging 10
liberal celebrities in which the
majority are oh like literally - I
probably post the same exact post three
times a day with 10 to 20 more people
tagged oh you know this all you need is
one of them to like repost it and you're
off to the [ __ ] races
sweet sweet thanks for sure well talk to
you soon thanks alright going back to
Twitter first our getting on the boards
here doesn't give me one second just
want to talk for a second first our
getting here in the boards a lot of good
advice as well this morning really
enjoying it really enjoying my mornings
with you guys you know I'm probably
gonna be sad when I have to go back to
my real life and can't do tea with Gary
Vee anymore but I'm really enjoying it
I'm really enjoying the moments with you
I really appreciate everybody who's
sharing on Twitter and I'm just grateful
and I hope the advice is helping I
really want to go back to Brian one more
time I hope you saw the joy in that
man's face he had the courage to move
back in with his in with his in-laws a
lot of you can move in with your
grandparents your uncle your mom your
dad a best friend if they're willing to
there if we just had more humility in
the world and people were willing to
take a step back there was two steps
forward he had a home he just got
married but he was 30,000 in debt and by
selling the home and moving in with his
in-laws for four to six months and then
moving into apartment his world is so
much happier and who gives a [ __ ] if
everybody makes fun of you that you sold
your house or thinks you're a loser
like [ __ ] then like their life has
nothing to do with yours and vice versa
so that was just a real powerful one
I've been talking a lot about that
concept trading in your car like just
that stuff I'm very passionate about
that and and that's it so anyway going
back to some of these t-post real quick
and I'll be right
in a second Dustin Andrew Humphrey thank
you for sharing that Matt Bomer thank
you for sharing Matt I'm actually gonna
give you a father that I'm your 1638
follower all right that's what I'm ready
Christian how are you I'm doing great
how are you I'm very well where are you
from I'm from Kingston Jamaica
this is awesome to be talking to you
it's awesome to be talking to you my
friend what a beautiful country oh yes
it is and we are under the same
quarantine lockdown as most places in
the world so are there a lot of cases in
Jamaica we're up to 36 this morning so
our government's done a really good job
so far of doing containment and
quarantine so I have two questions one
kind of general one more specific but
let me give a little context I work for
a start-up insurance company here in
Kingston called iron rock and we
launched four years ago listed on the
local stock exchange to raise capital I
have a very small team only 14 people in
comparison the next largest guy has 80
out 90 our employees so really really
small and we use technology to to scale
we've gone from Greenfield zero dollars
in revenue on day one to just about five
million US dollars a year in gross
revenue so we're not doing bad after
four years my role here is what's what's
the what's what's the net revenue number
do you know yeah the net revenue is
about I can do it in J dollars I haven't
converted it to you so my role here is
under general manager in charge of
production sales including marketing and
my kind of objective is to make iron
rock the cool tech insurance company
were small typically everybody hates
insurance insurance is not a real sexy
field in its kind of study stuff you're
very old school and so we we want to
create content that that positions us as
different as young as hip as the cool
tech insurance company because we're so
small we outsource all of our
social creation to a to another small
company it's not done in-house because
the team is really small we're on
Facebook and IG and I just finished
reading your book by the way Jab Jab Jab
right hook and it was awesome thank you
very much but what he showed me was that
the bulk of our content has been right
hooks on an rocks page and so I'm kind
of making a switch no to go and focus
more on jabs
and I am the persona and the voice of
the company in the social hood space and
so I've created my own personal page
christian wat je and i'm struggling with
what to post so I want to explain our
our thing and ion Rockets to simplify
insurance it's a technical thing people
don't like it people think we always
with you off so my goal is I want to
simplify explain the coverage explain
how it really works and when I've done a
few of those videos on iron rocks page
the engagement is 10 15 20 times higher
than any of the right hook posts
anything yeah anything valuable people
like anything that's asking them for
their money people don't like it's not
complicated exactly so but I'm trying
until should I post them so one quick
question should I post them as iron rock
J is page or as me the general manager
oh those s'posed as me and then put it
to the page as well so trying to create
it it's it's a bit stuffy it's a bit
boring sometimes what kind of angle is
my first general question would be good
to create engagement um it's about
creativity so for example I would
probably go to a jerk chicken stand and
literally film it from there and maybe
even ask the person that's serving you
hey like while you're doing your video
you're like oh by the way do you have
insurance and then of course something
funny is gonna happen they're gonna say
I don't [ __ ] you know it just it's
just making it more interesting right
from my desk in my rights do not do now
you know I think when people think about
how Facebook and Instagram work if
already behind you as a sunny jerk
chicken stand that's already more
interesting that's already more
irrelevant think about the other 500
things that matter to Jamaicans whether
you know whether its landmarks or silly
so I think setting a lot of times
setting the setting is very powerful
okay okay and my second question was
something more specific so I had an idea
for particular I guess theme or hashtag
that I wanted to create because
everybody has this stigma for insurance
I wanted to create a conversation around
a hashtag everyone hates insurance but
I'm kinda nervous you do because I don't
know if I should be associated with a
hashtag like that of course yeah of
course you should because because the
because when you dig into it it's it's
you're being empathetic to the consumer
okay right you're aligning yourself with
the customer got it and try and get
feedback from them as to why they hey
what's their issues what's our problems
your your act your with them instead of
being upset at them for hating insurance
gotcha gotcha gotcha those are my two
questions Jerry I I've been following
question what one other thing last thing
if you look at insurance success in Asia
in America in Europe a lot of the things
that work are irrelevant right
irreverence excuse me your reverence
so Geico or you know or progressive like
they're the creative is around something
that has nothing to do with insurance so
right I think humor something a little
bit different if you go make a video of
you just being in your stodgy suit
running and like literally filming while
you run in between a soccer a football
match on the beach with some kids or
some people and just get their reactions
there's something there okay you see
where I'm going yeah yeah try and use
humor and trying to stay away from
direct insurance and something that has
like doesn't make any sense it's just a
man in a suit running across a beach
where people and they're mad at you and
it just it's try [ __ ] try [ __ ]
yeah okay all right all right thank you
you're welcome
let's keep this going
Jamaica Greece got really international
tonight hello what's your name I'm
Deanna nice to meet you
yeah that's so nice to meet you I a
little bit about me first I am a
university student in Virginia I study
biomedical science and I'm a Spanish
minor my passion is in the medical field
as well as with Spanish so I'd like to
make you so that I recently got an
internship in Colombia the country and
you know it's expensive to do it but
that leads to my first question how
would you like if you were in my
position how would you fund that trip
and I have a little bit of time to do it
my my favorite thing to push people
towards is to sell something you know I
just I think it's been remarkable for me
over the last two years to see people
that have gotten into flip culture you
know like when I see this stuff even
over your shoulder right now like those
cups up there bugs you know chach
because I'm always like do you still
care about them are they're yours you
know like you know like you know I
always think in terms of like you know
if one has the ability to sell to buy
something and sell it starting with the
stuff laying around their house that
they don't like anymore and then going
to Goodwill garage sales you know thrift
stores buying bulk on eBay and selling
it on Amazon gianna nothing nothing
accelerates creation of like revenue
better than somebody not realizing they
were good at flipping and selling stuff
and then them trying it and being good
at it I mean I see I see people who
started at zero six months ago take
screenshots of their eBay account
showing me four or five seven nine ten
$12,000
because they got good at it so I don't
know if that's in you some people are
really bad at it and really don't like
the process of it but that would be
number one number two would be to you
know really just add more on my back so
just good old-fashioned grinding more
another job while I am in university
that's just real talk you know like when
you're in that position you know number
three just to go through all the
variables I would speak to every
relative and play a borrow game like
straight up like I think too many kids
ask for money instead of borrowing money
so going to like your great uncle and
being like yo I will pay you back in two
years the five hundred bucks it would
mean the world to me I'm in a tough spot
I don't think there's anything wrong
with borrowing money from relatives you
know I wouldn't put I wouldn't put a
stigma around that if you're feeling
that stress but you know really besides
doing something that you can do for
yourself to make money entrepreneurially
like the flippin getting a job just
another job and saving a grind job
late-night job or borrowing money those
are the three paths in this scenario in
my opinion okay have you ever sold
anything on eBay or Craigslist or
Facebook marketplace or Macari I don't
have much to sell understood how do you
have 20 bucks yeah yeah just a little
bit more than 20 bucks you know to me
there's a great story I got an email
where somebody was in a very similar
spot when I started talking about flip
life and they literally started with 20
bucks literally you know you're in a
little bit of a tough spot because we're
in quarantine right now but what they
did was they went to Goodwill they went
to some thrift stores they bought like
I'm trying to remember story 7 to 10
items they sold that on eBay and
Craigslist and Facebook marketplace they
got they made a hundred on that then
we're back it's just that process it you
know that I'm very passionate about the
the less entrepreneurial version is just
another [ __ ] job or number three just
borrowing money and there's that just
you know the
is not not that many options they fall
in the bucket of making it for yourself
you know by the way another way to make
money is labor not buying and selling so
maybe it is you know cutting here maybe
it is mowing lawns maybe it is like like
the reality is it's just grind life you
know okay and and then number four is
taking a step back and saying [ __ ] even
though this opportunity for this
internship in Columbia is so remarkable
I am NOT in a place right now where I
can actually afford it so let me go next
year if - whether it's Columbia Peru or
somewhere else that maybe I keep like
this is just not the right timing
even though [ __ ] I really want to that's
okay because you're a young woman and
sometimes you know disappointment like
that
is the Ignite to some of the other three
things that I told you are options okay
I wish you well I wish I have thank you
after two other questions as well that's
okay okay let's go quick okay I want to
start a non-profit once I become
established as a doctor and hopefully in
one of the so-called third world
countries thank you and I was wondering
if you had any advice as to how to start
that there's a semi an email when this
is done to Gary at vaynermedia I'm gonna
send you to books I'm on the board of
one pencils of promise and I'm a well
member to charity:water
both of the founders Adam it's God had
written books that are just remarkable
on how they started from zero zero as
kids and started these massive
nonprofits I think you should read them
I'm gonna send you both books thank you
so email me - Gary of vaynermedia and
put your address in there and I'm gonna
send you both books okay and then my
last question is for my dad he wants to
be a kind of an entrepreneur a business
owner and I was wondering what advice
would you have for him to start off he's
almost 50 and you know he's juggling
yeah he's young you know what I think
the right answer here is I'm gonna add
five more books all five business books
that I've written and I'm gonna send it
to him tell him to start watching my
content and other people's
content he needs to get educated on the
modern moments about Japan worship and
then decide to start a business around
something he loves
that will work most that is the highest
likelihood to success okay all right
thanks to you thank you so much Gary
yeah
Gary at vaynermedia bring your dress in
there okay thank you so much you're
welcome tea with Gary be brought to you
by this white mug by the way that's been
funny been getting beat up by a lot of
tea companies a lot of mud companies for
sponsorship that's crazy
Ronnie you know like his good bro how
are you I'm doing great man I can't
believe I'm on here talking to you you
are like next to my mom thank you so
much where are you at super grateful I'm
in a town called New Braunfels Texas
right between San Antonio and Austin
understood so ma'am my question really I
feel kind of like a couple of other
people you've talked to you like I'm so
happy where I'm at in my life I'm a
videographer photographer or social
media practitioner here in my town about
80,000 people you know and I made
content for small businesses help them
promote themselves on the internet and
that's what I love doing the content
creation is just that's my passion but
you know for the past three years I was
able to also take some your advice and
create kind of like a hyperlocal news
source on you know primarily Facebook
and Instagram it's gotten a lot of
attention with the local community I
mean they look to it or you know
breaking news a lot of time it's it's
business and entertainment oriented it's
not so much hard news but you know I
find myself in a place where I've got
this this really loyal audience that's
super engaged a ton of attention and I
have you know some friends and people
that are you know colleagues and in the
same space they're always kind of
encouraging me to figure out more ways
to monetize that side of my business you
know is the way I look at it is I've got
the content creation side and the
distribution side and you know my
passion is with the content creation
I'm not necessary I don't feel like I'm
a businessman I feel like I'm an
entrepreneur but I built this platform
out and it kind of just provides a ton
of value to the community and never and
we and Embree
awareness to you that may lead to
business on the other side 100
absolutely you you are monetizing it I
am yeah your your friends are looking at
it one-dimensional for sure I guess the
only thing the only reason I hesitate
and they catch my attention when they
say that is because you know like you
always say man I feel like I've already
won I'm doing you know what I love to do
but that being said like you know I
would love to turn this into a real
business instead of just a one-man show
and have you considered have you
considered bringing in a young hustler
Sara Rick who really have hunger who
loved a news or distribution side of
things who you might be able to give
five to 49 percent depending on how
great you feel about them to really
drive that side I teamed up with a good
friend of mine and we try to do that for
a little while it didn't work out but
you know I think just talking to you yes
you're just saying it out loud just
because one thing didn't work out
doesn't mean the next one can't the
other thing you can do is say hey listen
let's let's just let's let's roleplay
I'm Javier and you're I'm trying to and
yours and actually you be Xavier I'll be
you and I'll be like listen I'm here
listen I really like I'd really enjoyed
our two meetings I think you might be
the guy I love that you intern at CNN
that year I love that you've worked on
local websites I had a really tough
experience or not even tough I had an
experience that didn't work out with a
foreign friend I'm scared to give up
equity for this baby this is my baby but
I'm gonna do what other startups do with
you like if you're willing to take the
risk khabira I hope you can tell that
I'm a good guy
here's what I'd like to do I'd like to
pay you a little bit in year one for it
but after six months if it's working
then you can kick in to getting 10% of
it but if it doesn't work after six
months you're gonna have to trust me I'm
not a bad guy I'm just trying to protect
myself because right now I would say no
because I'm scared to give you 10% and
then it to not work out and then I
regret it so just like it's called a
cliff Javier in other startups where you
work until you hit one-year you don't
get any equity I'd like to cliff you for
the first six months if you go great
then you go your vulnerability is me
trying to screw you or you're deciding
that you weren't good enough but
is what I'm offering and I do have 20
other people that are interested but I
think you're my guy I think that's the
combo Rodney yeah got it man
hi Gary again man honestly more
important than any question I can ask I
wanna say thanks for everything that you
do for our community man Ronnie I think
that you should thank you brother Ronnie
I think you should reach out to every
local business and do an interview right
now with them on zoom on Instagram
record it like it right now with all
this downtime if I'm hearing you
straight one-on-one interviews five
minutes on how they're getting through
this how they are give them one minute
DM speed round to promote their business
I would [ __ ] me 25 of those a day if
I were you I would literally I would go
Pam right now I would go 24 hours
breaking news aka your version 20
business interviews a [ __ ] day you
don't need to edit them you just record
them and post them with a little copy
you do four minutes on how you're
handling it what's your you know what
are you thinking about you know I almost
I do in five minutes two minutes on
their background in the community two
minutes on how they're handling it and
one minute to promote their business it
would be such a public service yeah I
did that last week like two or three
times people loved it and then I just
stopped I mean it was a lot of wonderful
the whole Cove in nineteen being
covering some of this stuff it just kind
of drained because it was kind of just
super you know heavy for what I'm used
to producing I think you can go the
other way let's go with optimism on it
you know this is an optimist to make it
optimistic like roller towards optimism
sure awesome but I'll talk to you thank
you any more okay thanks rod all right
let's keep going back to Twitter if
you're watching right now let's uh time
does fly time flies when you're
listening it's true
like this is going super fun fast and
fun hi hey Vicky good to see you give me
one second just trying to Chris Paul um
I'm gonna follow you my friend I've been
around the file Thank You great to see
you how you doing
well I'm sure you're challenged with
this this Cobra because an ice cream
store is not necessarily in the best
position during this time no plus
obviously we're in a tourism would
normally be hotspot with spring break
and commerce he clear ball to hit the
news because it was doing the wrong
thing so kind of all the mom-and-pop
shops absolutely challenge to do the
right thing and keep it safe we closed
for a few days which was absolutely dire
because spring breaks when obviously we
were hoping to put money back in the pot
because we just spent all of our savings
on the new store so that obviously it's
going to take a long time to recover but
yes forward my concern is now obviously
all the people that were going to come
down this year for tourism are not going
to come so there's when when it does
finally get back to a little bit of
normality but tourism we're still gonna
be at the back end of the queue to
survive and so we've done
curbside for the last three days which I
wasn't sure initially it would work
because I needed to work out a way they
could be safe and we did minimum four
pine ice cream do prepay buy invoice
when you arrive call us it gets brought
out so we kind of all the friction that
was amazing because we've just managed
to bring in some money but obviously
that's a short-term stop to getting
anywhere near close to what we should be
doing you know unfortunately and I've
been thinking about you because I saw
you on social a little bit and you know
so it's on my mind I was like kind of
like racking my brain unfortunately you
know it's the same thing with all my
restaurant friends in New York there's
only so much you can do you know we you
know we've lost some clients on the
Boehner side that are selling clothes
right and just they're you know the
retail clothes and just like even the
online clothes players are not doing
well because that's just not what people
are thinking about right now and so you
know unfortunately also having a
seasonal business where it's not like
you know you
open and we're just back to our building
back up to our normal mean and it's just
all the same the reality is is no
different than a hurricane no different
than a war no different than you know an
earthquake you know that ship that takes
down a highway and then hurts all those
businesses in New York no different than
when they decide to put up a subway
station and they close one side of the
street and you're on that side of the
street there are this is what's so scary
and real about entrepreneurship
sometimes there is no answer and and
that doesn't mean give up what it means
is you can only do what you can do and I
think one of the reasons Vicki and I
know you watch a lot of the content the
story time thing is the thing that I'm
most focused on right now cuz it's the
one thing that everybody can control the
trials like just you know the reality is
putting out content about the stories or
about the product or you can how you
came up with the recipes is really at
some level besides the promotion of
kerbside for you are really the two
options that you have to actually attack
other than that were at the mercy of
like the reality of the situation
yeah I think I think is well the hardest
thing for me having obviously come from
the UK to the arrest and obviously every
single bit of savings and we save for
three years we had a nice pot of money
which was just saved because I knew we
would have to move locations so then
they have that pot of money and put 90 K
in to the new store and then be looking
at my bank account and going [ __ ] I I've
got stuff to think about and the
backstop that I've had for 16 years of
retail in London and us for the first
time in my life at the worst possible
point I don't have that kind of fall
back I mean I mean I've got amazing
stuff all the young kids live at home
and they're alright don't worry about us
which is great I've got one full time
member of staff which oversee and her
and I are kind of clean to look all what
we can to kind of keep it going but it
cooks like everybody else been an
immigrant our visas do for a renewal
this year so we also have to at some
point go back to London and obviously
show them
see that we're worthy to be able to stay
in the US for another five years it's a
challenge for the good news there is my
intuition on the reopen the five years
the the kovat scenario is probably gonna
help you I think a lot of people are
gonna get passes based on that so I
would argue that that will probably work
out I would also argue that this is a
real challenge and I think you know much
like we talked when you were in New York
at the forties like I still think an
icepack direct-to-consumer not just
relying on your local area is something
that you're gonna have to consider
shipping ice cream in pints around the
country is something you have to
consider it's just something you have to
consider
I would I would spend a lot of time
right now on the packaging you know what
I'd probably do if I were you I'd
probably and you might have done this
already so this is more general
information for people I probably order
five to seven pints of ice cream from
people who do ship around the country
just to see how they ship it you know
what did they you know I we're launching
a food version of wine Tech's called
yummy text we actually already have and
we're we're doing a lot of that right
now because we have a lot of soft cheese
we don't want to melt you know that kind
of stuff but I really think Vicki like
Irene and you've become my friend
through this process I will I rarely do
this but I would absolutely give
awareness to you would really promote it
if you like I really think you have to
have a meaningful direct-to-consumer
national shipping ice cream model and
you have to make sure it doesn't melt
from Clearwater to San Jose I think
that's to be a challenge because I was
here reliant on the carriers and you're
also relying on the airlines we did look
at it before and there's a kind of whole
host of you have to get nutritional
content on it on each thing and
obviously all the allergies and stuff
and that's where I kind of fell down
because the nutritional content is like
then it's expensive because it all has
to get sent away to kind of work out so
I mean I just I just don't think I I
don't know all those details but I can
tell you right now some things are
required for long term success I
I couldn't be more passionate of you
figuring out how to ship ice cream yeah
I just could I couldn't period and maybe
you know when I hear what you're saying
I'm like man I hope they didn't make it
more complicated than it actually is
like I would just really I would really
recommend ordering five from five
different places that do ship ice cream
to your home right now and like reverse
engineer how they did it yeah yeah we'll
appreciate we help connect stay cool I
wish you well take care everyone
Nikki direct-to-consumer ice cream I
will help you I will I will put out two
to three pieces of content which there
you go you just saved eighty thousand
dollars in marketing promotion I will do
that for you because I want to but I
really want you to take it serious you
need to get some of that coffee ice
cream you know how much I love it
love you bye love you bye
you know some circumstances are just
more challenging than others you know
you know Vicky's ice cream the last two
right D doesn't have anything to sell in
her house you know I'm like hey so
Stephanie now she's like oh god [ __ ]
right and ice cream in a town in Florida
like that seasonal that doesn't you know
there's some real tough situations out
there but we're gonna fight and look for
angles and keep chipping away let's keep
going a team of Gary B hey what's up
Gary how are you brother good good I
appreciate you having me on today happy
to do it um I just wanna say thank you
cuz uh back in 2018 when you had your
crusher book signing I was one of the
people that came out and you ended up
signing this for me and I remember you
stuck around like you were trying to get
out for your family and you ended up
like literally staying like an hour over
just to like get everybody through so I
that means the world thank you for
seeing that you're welcome um yes I
guess I just had a couple questions for
you so I do fashion photography but in
New York and basically yes decided to go
like nice you know cuz I
over the years kind of like perfected
what my craft is and um it's I've
decided to go into fashion and uh I
guess do you have any advice like for me
like going forward like is there
anything I could do differently what do
you want to happen to build brand
awareness around yourself so that people
book you pretty much yet more brand
stuff yeah for um all like different
brands you know I think a signature when
I hear that I think a signature play
like a podcast or a youtube show I'm a
very big believer in a signature product
and then you build from all the concept
of that I mean even look what I'm doing
right now it's very meta even this
downtown I'm like [ __ ] it I'm gonna
create something signature tea with Gary
B and then all of its gonna scream from
that it's how I started Wine Library TV
it's how you know my whole world has
gone so I think look you're trying to
build awareness that you're good at
something or get known in a sector so
let me explain how this works if you
start up you know in fashion if you
started let me go very nice shirt um
fashion in social weekly brought to you
by Lawrence crookston right right like
if that's the show literally if you
named it that show and then emailed and
LinkedIn messaged 50 of the top fashion
designers in the world or fashion CEOs
or fashion creative directors 50 50 I'm
talking top people you would be blown
away you have nobody watching your show
you would be blown away that two of them
would say yes to be a guest now why
that's important Lawrence is now all of
a sudden you're on the phone for 35
minutes 45 minutes or in person for 45
minutes with a chief creative officer of
Stuart Weitzman and when you're done
that person's like that's like so what
are you doing like oh I'm actually a
fashion you see where I'm going you're
putting yourself in a position to
network through bringing value that's
how I think about it okay so literally
like me me like
and weekly with Lawrence come up you
come up with something you know like
this week in fashion is very generic but
maybe this week in New York fashion is
nice enough and so you've limited
yourself to New York fashion but at the
same token there's [ __ ] thousands of
people you need to meet in New York
fashion you say you'll probably never
get to everybody in your pod you see
where I'm going
yeah like even like what I do is around
York Fashion Week I'll literally like I
I work as like my day job where I like
make coffees and sandwiches and stuff so
all I'll get up early in the morning hit
up fashion and we get on the streets and
meet like influencers and editors and
and kind of build relationships like
that and then go do my day job and then
you know go home and edit all the photos
and try to build those connections
I think hosting a podcast around the
industry that I mean you called fashion
photographer weekly you know it's like I
like it going macro because I want you
to invite the most important people and
get once you get five of them two of
them you can get anybody and all of a
sudden your podcast is why you're
booking you know more photography
because you're letting them talk about
their business and it's like it's like a
good trade you're giving them a platform
even though nobody's listening at first
people still love giving interviews and
what you're getting is awareness and
networking capabilities that may lead to
something okay you gotta probably talk
to you soon thanks Lawrence Dallas
Barnes just followed you thank you for
sharing a screenshot if you're watching
now take a screenshot of this and post
it on your Twitter and and let everybody
know what you're watching and I'm trying
to get some more people in here to watch
because it's super fun and I think we're
bringing a lot of value and I'm also
looking to do some fun stuff so I see
that luke Churchill here has me and his
profile so I just like this I appreciate
that Luke it's nice meeting you the
other day Isabelle start Stark
appreciate you watching thank you so
much for that I'm really appreciative of
that Dustin I'm ready for next one
hi Ashley hey Gary how are you well I'm
super nervous excited don't be nervous
and just be excited so what the help us
thank you thank you so much for having
me part of my thing was just doing this
I've been but sort of hiding out for a
while and what better way to break the
ice
yeah well what do you like I used to do
a lot of video and I used to do our
lives and went through some challenging
times and then now I work I do a lot
with video right now but not in front of
camera so for you I'm glad you did it
thank you thank you thank you for having
me and I'm just I'm just so incredibly
impressed with you
and your kindness like just listening to
everything that you're doing for for
everyone just although these callers
it's just it's just such a true act of
just kindness and I just want to call
that out first thank you for saying that
so my thing is it's such an interesting
moment I'm both oddly inspired and
excited and equally fast and you know
holding the compassion in my heart for
what people who are having hard moments
for experiencing right now I feel
exactly the same way and also at the
same moment it's like that excitement
for truth yes for there's an opportunity
and truth and and for pause you know
pausing is powerful and I think a lot of
people are gonna get in their heads in a
different way and I do think gratitude
is gonna emerge for many and and I think
cynicism for others you know a lot of
people are gonna who are insecure and
who are cynical are gonna be like see I
just was on the verge of having it all
figured out and then Corona came this is
a half glass empty half last full moment
no question yeah so from so for me I I
was I was literally right before this
was happening sort of
re looking at for myself sort of the
opportunity that presented itself was I
have an eye for capturing video and
really understanding like these nuggets
and these these powerful to three
minutes of content and and a couple of
years ago I actually actually developed
a video business card and I created you
know I had 50 people go through it and
and so it was called vid myths so I was
super excited and I was about to sort of
take flight and then um unfortunately my
father who was ill at the time it was
time to go home and be with them so that
that took precedence so um when I got
back from that it's like I just couldn't
get going I couldn't I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it but after many years of
working for myself and different
businesses like okay I guess I gotta go
work for someone else right now I just
don't have it and myself and that's okay
I mean it was because it brought me to
some really interesting opportunities
and I got do things good which has been
great and now I've you know this year
has been great I've been getting back
and and so here I am now in this other
place with these sort of video nuggets
and these and and I was like wow I
actually have a business name fitbit's
and I'm talking about small pieces of
content and I actually have a team that
can create them so it just started
falling into place and I'm doing them
currently and but then this happened and
it's like well you know is it is it the
moment is it the you know just how I
should show up in this moment how I
chose down myself yeah I think actually
I think the biggest thing is a
relationship with time right like you
know the reality is if it is or isn't
the moment I don't view that as some
huge if it's not the moment I don't view
that as some huge negative because the
reality is within six months or 12
months it
I'd be the moment and of course you know
we all have to cherish every moment
we're on earth and you never know what
can happen tomorrow but knock on wood
there's a likely chance that you've got
a good 40 in you years and and and I
think and I think you know when you
actually contextualize that I think
that's you know your natural
entrepreneurship because you went that
way your own your own time clock on
ideology like should you be working for
somebody else or should you not your own
ambition an ideology like who you are
and what you are and and should you be
doing this or not the reality is and
this is a very powerful answer it's
funny like how I feel about this answer
it doesn't matter
do you know like like meet what I mean
by that it's really powerful and I'm
starting to realize why so much works
for me whether I'm right or wrong
whether it leads to the next great thing
or it literally becomes the seed of my
ultimate financial demise it really is
all gonna be okay
like to think what you know like and I
mean it I really am very passionate
about perspective right to your point
going through a fog did your dad pass
yeah big shout out to mom like like you
know like I'm sure your dad had lots of
thoughts about life the whole way and
then like ultimately like what right
like like we just live and so like I
just want to encourage you to realize
there is no wrong answer I mean that I
really believe that because I always
tell people I give you a good example
somebody really in my inner circle broke
down with kovat inner circle solid
acquaintance - maybe borderline friend
right and you know like a friend a
friend I was just right there I did it
like you know like really like went and
I was like and and I was talking to him
and I said something that really swung
him and I and I say it a lot if you
really follow me I don't say it that
often but if you follow me you've heard
this I said look bro I get it but like
let's just roleplay for a second let's
take a step back and reframe our
perspective let's say this didn't happen
hope it didn't happen and let's say you
would have gone to
that pitch that would have gotten you
this money that he's talking about like
let's just say they even said yes and
then let's say that you were happy and
on the phone and calling your wife after
and saying you're getting the money and
you weren't paying attention and you
literally literally got across the
street in Chicago and died I'm like you
do understand that that's possible you
do understand that you know for all the
deaths that are gonna come from this
disease there are gonna be handfuls
hundreds if not thousands of people
around the world who this actually saved
their life because they wouldn't have
gone to that restaurant and choked on
that chicken boat because they wouldn't
have gone on that flight where they
would have gotten the radioactive mist
that led to their camps like I actually
believe that actually I and I think and
when I say it doesn't matter what I mean
by that is we all do our best and trying
to make decisions but if we actually
realized the ones that may seem like bad
decisions on paper up front actually led
to being great decision seven years
later there's something that I'm able to
do through my DNA upbringing and
perspective and malpractice and is just
realizing you got to give things time to
figure out if they were right or wrong
and everybody like wants to judge
everything so short you see what I mean
yeah no I totally get that and I really
I feel like I've I've learned to
practice that more and more especially
in the last couple of years just good
you know that patience yeah and
gratitude right even pretty I mean every
day everyone's like this suck this sucks
I'm like you and I are talking right now
because of modern technology if this
happened in 1987 like like that that you
know that we would have missed out on a
ton of human interaction that really
right now people are getting their fix
on human interaction look what we're
doing I'll give you one ash I'll give
you one let's go very meta I might have
said something in the right way at the
right moment to you now that will bring
you value there's no [ __ ] way I'm
doing tea with Gary Vee if there was no
comment I mean later right that we need
to understand that life is unbelievably
complex and layered and we need to lean
into optimism and gratitude and whether
it's time for bits or not I just think
that you should think that every
decision is right and I think most
people think every decision is wrong
like most people just go into like did I
make the right this there's just this
unbelievable ability to beat oneself up
to be cynical to be pessimistic to be
fear-based and I'm just trying to get
people to flip it because life is
actually how it plays out in your head
it just actually is like my ability to
turn every negative into a positive
is very real and and I watched many
people taking positives and turning into
negatives it's very real life is a
perspective game and we need to have
more positive optimism yet 100% thank
you so much an incredible experience
just watching news every morning thank
you so thank you so much take care man
that was fun I really believe in that
[ __ ] I really really really do Rock
Dance Theatre thank you so much for
sharing Mike Turner thank you for tea
with Gary you get it you get a follow
hey Mike Turner I'm gonna reply to you
right now do you drink wine this is me
asking you because then I want to tell
you this on story context calm you're
watching right now and if you've gotten
value out of these you know she would go
to these and you drink wine wine texts
calm Bianca how are you oh my gosh I'm
good I am so excited I've been up since
5:00 a.m. my time hoping to be on your
Seattle oh yeah how are you yes I'm good
so my question is obviously for the
first time I'm laid off and all of the
not enough time problems have kind of
gone away but I've also been a little
bit paralyzing because now I'm like I
have all these ideas and I'm like don't
know where to go first so I've kind of
narrowed it down to two like main ideas
I'm a dance teacher and I have this idea
of like a like online dance program for
beginners but my kind of where my heart
wants to go is more into like a coaching
business last summer I did a leadership
program it kind of just shifted my whole
world and so I got a lot of practice and
experience coaching and I would love to
this bianco me to give you I'm gonna
give you a direct tangible prescription
cuz it's so obvious to me you ready yeah
I would like you to do some I want you
to start a Facebook group and I want you
to start a zoom session and literally
spam and I'm using spam is kind of like
a slang term I want you to post on your
Facebook and your Instagram that you're
going on zoom and you inviting people
and if you'd like you to come on and
just shoot the [ __ ] with me we're gonna
talk about leadership and and thought
and mindset I want you to go I want you
to go into action I want you to go
directly into doing what I'm doing with
tea with Gary Vee but I want you to do
it in a group setting I want you to get
five 10 15 people into a zoom and
literally just shoot the [ __ ] or a
Google hangout or whatever works for you
so I literally want you to start doing
it you have a hypothesis in your heart
like just go and just shoot the [ __ ]
about life or whatever I also need you
desperately to make to dance videos on
tick-tock every single day I had a
feeling you're gonna say that Bianca I'm
telling you it's very real what people
don't like as you were thinking people
are crippled by I have 10 ideas people
are crippled by I've narrowed it down to
two which one's the right one and what
people don't understand is in today's
Internet the answer is yes and both and
the answer is and like literally by this
afternoon in seven hours in ten hours
you should have to tick-tock dance
videos and in your profile it should say
dance teacher with your email and at six
o'clock at night tonight you know which
would be 9:00 on the East Coast you
should be doing a little wine happy our
leadership mindset like kind of little
jam session that you're the [ __ ]
queen bee of that you're leading here's
the topic here's the questions and
literally in 24 hours you've now started
the process of figuring out the right
answer through action not through debate
got it yeah so you you would suggest
just like getting a group of people on
Facebook is what I'm hearing and then
coming up with kind of like a format
beforehand and just like some questions
maybe to throw out or yeah kinda walks
in the mechanics of it you know yeah I'm
gonna get you unmechanical
get seven to ten people into a Google
hangout because I want them to be
physically on their post on your
Facebook post on your Instagram email
your entire address book and be like I'm
doing a leadership a free litter ship
seminar I know a lot of us are bored I'm
getting on FaceTime grab your cup of
coffee grab a glass of wine and then
when you get there just talk okay
because I mean it's very easy the first
ones like how is everybody literally
you're like how's everybody getting
through this that's a good starting
point you know in a minute and then tell
everybody why you're I mean literally be
like hey nine hours ago Gary Vee was
yelling at me
auntie with Gary Vee to do this that's
why it's happening and then tell them
what happened a year ago how much you
loved it and while you're doing it just
start shooting the [ __ ] conversate okay
listenmi making and doing is the only
answer and everybody plays life in their
head and I want anybody to play their
life in life I love it I love it because
because both of your good debates you're
gonna have if you do what I just said to
you every day for two weeks here you're
gonna have a much better feel of which
one what if it was actually dancing and
it was about tick tock explosion and
getting virtual dance classes and
getting rates that you never could have
a man imagined and maybe you loved it
more and maybe in that dance class you
do do some leadership and mindset and
life coaching and they like said you got
a do too you got a taste you got a try
you got a make you got a gem and
everyone just sits in the room and
thanks and Ponder's yes totally
relatable yeah uh everybody Ponder's and
I want everybody to play right I want
everybody I do more playing less
pondering right yeah yeah no I love your
suggestion because because I get kind of
lost in that details I I don't always
connect like the way to just get out
there and try something because I get so
lost and they'll like then those people
are instead
most people are insecure and think they
need to have it right to do it
it's it's the manifestation of
insecurity great well I'm really I
really appreciate your work because
you've definitely helped me sift out of
that good I'm definitely more willing to
just like post things and just kind of
see if people like it or not and because
because their opinions don't matter like
[ __ ] them if they say you suck [ __ ] them
hole it's true it's true it's true like
okay cool
sorry Randy the mailman you think I'm an
idiot cool like sorry aunt June I'm
sorry aunt June that you think this is
silly
you go worry about your [ __ ] cat you
know like you know what I mean like what
yeah yeah that's right thank you so much
you're welcome
take care all right getting towards the
end of another episode of tea with Gary
B Valerie is in the building
hey Belle hi how are you good can you
hear me I can't awesome
I'm also from Seattle so I feel like I'm
okay god this is so great that we have
this opportunity like our grandparents
would never have been able to do this
right so I'm doing this right now you're
providing so much value to everyone and
I just I'm super stoked so yeah yeah I
have been listening to you and been
really inspired and my passion kind of
similar actually and I work in the
corporate and world and nonprofit
healthcare and I would love to kind of
get in the space of being like a
consultant for different businesses and
employee engagement like via positive
psychology so similar question how would
you do that like how would you begin to
scale that obviously LinkedIn is like my
game right now but I'm a little
concerned of like posting on there and
just because I'm currently I don't know
void so so I think I think I think but I
actually think you can get away with it
and the way you do that is by making it
as general thoughts sharing more so than
hire me
to do this you're just building your
awareness and you're just sharing your
thoughts on these issues you're almost
you're almost journaling you know you're
almost sharing okay and that's not like
threatening to my current it may be it
may be I do I do the problem is then
you're out of options right like like
the way to do it is one of the couple
ways one the way to actually build up
demand is through creating the content
that leads to awareness to your point if
that's detrimental to your org look the
reality is is that most if you can make
it general enough most orgs most
companies have a very unique
relationship with their employees
unfortunately most companies want to
keep their employees in jail I on the
other hand am desperate to build up the
profiles of my employees
James Rossini Nick do Claude silver
d-roc like I want them to build up their
profiles because I think that's karma
and the world is abundant and if they
feel that they can do better outside of
my four walls
I want that for them I don't want to
suppress them I have empathy that that
might not be the case for your situation
but I think the more general and
non-threatening you go the if you're not
asking for business then you're just
building awareness around the subject
matter and then if they're just super
cynical then you may have to deal with
that right so I guess the follow-up
question for you is how do we get more
leaders to be influential in a way that
you are how do we incorporate more
positivity and you know the leadership
that you bring to the team in your
opinion I think we find the ones that
are naturally are in it because a lot of
people aren't many leader right lead
with fear and I don't think we're gonna
be able to change I don't think we'd be
able to change them overnight I think we
can hang the ball down the field and
have them debate but I think the way we
do it is actually triple down on the
people that have it naturally in them
and build awareness towards that right
like for example I think there's a lot
of 24 year olds who had it in them who
because they now look up to me
we'll do more of it then they would have
had I not existed and I feel like that's
a legacy that I'm proud of right right
so kind of capitalize on those ones that
are the rising stars or that are doing
it already and just go big on that okay
that's right bow because most people's
intuition is to try to change the person
right is the leader but too much
parenting too much DNA too much culture
too much old dogs and tricks you could
get them from being a zero to a three on
the positivity and opting whereas
whereas but that would take years
whereas you could take somebody from a
natural four to a ten by just giving
them encouragement okay and then should
I also be posting on I mean obviously
other platforms as well but do you have
other techniques to kind of get myself
out there content creation obviously you
know it's so funny it's kind of like you
know it is concentration is it doing a
podcast where you start by interviewing
all the bosses in your own company which
means you you know it what I don't think
people understand is I say this a lot I
think I can tell that you're paying
attention it is like it is like exercise
and eating well the the formula to being
in shape is actually remarkably scary
simple the the discipline to execute is
hard my model is very simple I think you
should produce content on every single
platform in the world and I think that
you should do it every single day and
every waking hour and when you do a
podcast that it should be recorded and
post produced it's why I put out those
decks those you know slides you know you
know for anybody doesn't know what I'm
talking about just search Gary Vee deck
or Gary be content model on Google
you'll find it the the formula is real
the discipline to do it is hard yeah
absolutely I appreciate you so much and
the world anymore so much right now so
thank you thank you Bill Seattle back to
back I like that I like that
Cody what's good what's up Gary life is
good you hanging in there
getting into online classes and getting
adapting to that it is it is definitely
an intense intense variable is it are
you like enjoying it or is it like suck
um there's one class that is a little
difficult to kind of understand but he's
kind of splitting up into different
sections trying to get simpler and then
everything else seems to be smooth
sailing right now I'm actually using
museum I've never used soon before and
told this semester so I was glad to get
to know it because now look where I'm at
I get to use it and got to you it's
awesome what can I help you with brother
yeah so in the recent years I know that
you have emphasized on looking up like
you're where you live on Instagram and
seeing the top by post and interacting
with them the comments with my area I
live in Iowa Cedar Rapids Iowa and my
post don't really consist of like
creating content it's like really random
posts I don't really know how to
describe them so what do you suggest
what each what do you would woody well
what are you trying to accomplish I
would like to get myself out there to be
I'm I am saying to be an information
technologists in a computer support
specialist degree but I also like to do
videography so I was thinking it like
myself out there with making videos I
could help people around my town make a
video I understand yeah for their
businesses or whatever it is that they
do so I think you should put out videos
on your account mm-hm and then I think
he should DM all the businesses that
have an Instagram account in your area
and you should give them a pointer or
two don't tell them that you could do
videos for free yeah I mean you can say
I'll do videos for free cuz I think that
would work to some of them but I you
definitely shouldn't say hey why don't
you hire me to make a video you need a
video yeah well you should what you
should do is say let me let's roleplay
I'll write the email dear I was steel
curtains Iowa curtains
hope all is well was just stumbled on
your Instagram account I know a little
bit about content and social I noticed
on your Instagram account this is the DM
you're writing them Cody I noticed on
your Instagram account
you didn't link your website in your
Instagram profile you should definitely
do that because anybody that sees one of
your photos will then click to it that's
very basic they might I would sue 90% of
people will have their URL there but
that would be example you could say dear
Iowa Fried Chicken you know hope all is
well hope you're doing well with this
clomid hope your business is OK I'm Cody
I happen to know a lot about content and
social I stumbled on your page and I
happen to notice that you do get 30 to
40 comments per post but I look back in
the last year of your content and you've
never replied to anybody if you reply
you'll build a much stronger community
which will probably help you sell a lot
of chicken also I noticed you've done a
lot of pictures you should start mixing
in some video if Cody if you do that if
you make your / if you put out content
on your profile and you can you go DM
businesses in your area if your hope is
to get them to hire you to do videos for
them but you don't sell to them but you
provide them a free 5 minute
social media audit and DM them
I guarantee three of them oh if you DM
50 people a week 100 people a week I
guarantee three of them will become
clients yours I really believe in that
awesome
yep awesome awesome and good luck talk
to you soon yep thanks Gary all right I
gotta steal three minutes back for
prepping for this 11:00 a.m. call so
this was another episode of tea with
Gary Vee I hope you guys can join me
tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. Eastern tell all
your West Coast friends to wake up at
5:45 would love a barrage of feedback on
today's episode on on Twitter my team is
gonna be chopping this up it would mean
a lot to me if you went to Twitter right
now and said what your favorite part was
I might lead to some observations for me
and the team and it would show me all
the faces and accounts that have been
watching this morning so please go to
Twitter Gary Vee is my twitter handle if
you don't a Twitter account and you're
watching this please set up a Twitter
account go to Twitter right now and
set up a Twitter account you need a
Twitter account period and that's that
so we should well can't wait to see you
tomorrow
I love you guys hope you enjoyed Dustin
thank you so much for your help on the
ones that choose I blend them and we
will talk to everybody soon bye bye
everyone
you